I just want to know how he son comes
back and you sh us some pictures such a
disg by the way how you like
it like it as as pictur that you get yes
his son is a
coward the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tells us that our books will be given
and every little at and weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masid Allah you
helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you built
it donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra rewards 3 2
one go are we ready to smoke moly yes
let's go
inshallah brothers and sisters and dear
friends that's my daughter may Allah
bless you inshallah I have fre daughters
that's the grownup one M 6 years old and
this pertains to this inshallah brothers
and sisters Subhan Allah if you just
think about it yesterday hijab
absolutely smoked shamoli and he was
just interrupting talking about the
dubaii ruler and how he loves him
praising Islam he's my brother all these
kind of nonsense uh things trying to
emotionally you know uh our you know
heartstrings it doesn't work you are
somebody that supports the government
that is massacring uh Palestinian
children babies so how dare you even try
to shake Muhammad haab's hand how dare
you alhamdulillah Muhammad hijab did the
right thing by not shaking your damn
bloody hands yes here is a discussion
where just look at his reaction when
hijab asks him his his son meny or
whatever the H bloody is called who
works for this IDF terrorist
organization State yes if I had my son
who went and joined a group like Isis
for that matter I would wish and hope
and pray that he comes back to his
senses if not I would be happy that he
is rid of this Earth with all the
catastrophe and all the massacre and the
Guinness and people that he's been
killing but not for this man look how he
behaves right now in this video we're
going to watch now I just want to know
how he comes back you sh us the pictures
right such a disg by way how you like
it
my son know how L that you get you wife
you're not a real man real man don't
attack wom real men don't tell us
5-year-old girls can have sex real man
speak about another yes you did said on
my Instagram don't say that 5-year-old
girls creep you best and should have sex
you are talking about my son you're not
a real man you're a bul if you really
believe you really believe you would not
be in the
safety of a studio in London not bring
up my son not bring up St picking on wom
stop see you you want
sing debate but imagine saying that your
son your son is dead no morality you
have no decy you have no goodness and
this is because this man is here to
speak about my sex life he's here to say
my son's going to die see guys see how
he calls hijab they sickening low blow
how could you say this get my family
involved blah blah blah blah blah hijab
is making a very very very valid point
there look at he supports a state that
is massacring committing genocide an
apartheid state that is killing innocent
men women and children as we speak over
10 11,000 innocent kids have been
massacred and the moment he says and
gives him a taste of his own medicine
how how by saying if your son who is in
a terrorist State organization yes who
was in killing innocent people he he
gets upset he gets emotional the thought
of him losing his son on the battlefield
yes his son is a coward he's a pan
animous coward that's what he is because
he belongs to that organization and the
moment he is made even think about it he
loses his cool he loses his posture his
hand start shaking like hijab said you
know he starts shaking all that kind of
stuff but he will look at those pictures
and he will say this is sickening but he
is the same person under the same breath
justifying what Israel is doing
in the same breath he's telling us that
the Palestinians in the West Bank are
happy with occupiers can you believe
this can you believe this it's like the
whites in South Africa telling the
blacks that these people are okay with
us with apartheid system and they have
different rules for that matter
unbelievable you cannot make this up you
got owned shamoli the Unholy shami you
got schooled that's what you got you got
schooled that's what happened to you and
you will never forget that I've been
reading in the comment section and
people loved every second how hijab gave
you a taste of your damn medicine
brothers and sisters and you was
crumbling you are crumbling your state
this terrorist state is losing the
war PR wise and everyone in every
situation and this exposed you further
you are a coward we don't give a damn
how much good you know you've praised
Islam before it means nothing okay you
are somebody that supports that so much
so that you had an issue with hijab
calling Churchill what he did in Germany
that he's a war criminal you have an
issue with that why cuz you want the
British people to just side with you yes
he was a war criminal for that matter
okay he is a war criminal what he did
there was to our moral grounds for Islam
it is wrong you cannot indiscriminately
kill men women children for those matter
Islam doesn't work like that till next
time brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you guys and preserve you guys
share this you guys doing an amazing
work carry on posting sharing carry on
we are doing an amazing work all
together by showing the entire world the
true colors of Israel these people are
sadly the Zionist racist we want a state
where the Palestinians the Muslims and
the Christians live side by side just
like they did in the
past even brought brought those Jewish
families when they were kicked out by
the Christians themselves brought them
to live in peace together Muslims have
never ever had an issue with the Jewish
community ever they live side by side
unless those who committed treason but
other than that they live side by side
and the Muslims have no problem
anti-Semitism comes from the Crusaders
and the Christians not from us brothers
and sisters that's all I have to say may
Allah subh bless and preserve you guys
till next
time if you haven't watched debate you
have to just see how we got shoked the
Unholy
Shi I don't want to be around the bush
have you heard of the sav man no Masid
project your brothers and sisters at
Islam net are establishing a oneof its
kind Masjid da and Community Center in
the capital of Norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts Islam through this Center every
revert who learns about their Dean and
calls their family to the worship of
Allah subhana wa tala you will get the
rewards inshallah so here's what you
must do you must contribute to get your
rewards and share this project imagine
you meeting Allah subhana wa tala and
receiving the Glad Tidings of a palace
in Jenna because of this very Masid you
built with your s now you tell me what
Greater Joy can there be than getting a
house in Jenna with Gardens and rivers
of Honey walls built of bricks of gold
and silver mortar of fragrant musk
Pebbles of Pearl and Sapphire and soil
of saffron and whoever enters a house in
Jenna will be filled with joy and will
never feel miserable they will live
there forever and they will never die
they will get clothes that will never
wear out and the youth will Never Fade
Away Subhan Allah these are the
descriptions of the houses in Jenna that
our beloved Prophet peace be upon Him
gave to his beloved companions would you
not want that for your afterlife click
the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the
video